welcome to mailing it in you write I
read and you'll learn something new
that's a lie all right let's go to Alice
she asks this is a pretty good question
if you could inject truth serum into
anyone who would you choose Michelle oh
gosh you came to me first that's so
wrong come on
um
um Donald Trump Donald Trump but he's
the least no he's still no because you
know he tells the truth all the time
even while he's a lot his lies are truth
let's see I this you came to me first I
went there but see I think I wonder if
there is a like another part of the
truth in him that is like more based on
reality interesting ever escorted out
you have too many other choices you had
Kamala and Joe Biden and you choose the
greatest president we've ever had
Trace Trace I think you're right Joe
Biden Kamala Harris and
consider and say man I would like to be
funny again I would like to do the jokes
that people are gonna like but it can't
they've chosen aside and they are damned
if they're going to go exactly they
can't they I always think the late night
hosts are governed by their wives yeah
I don't know what that means
uh peers I would actually I'd like to
see Hunter Biden injected with Teresa
you know what he'd probably get addicted
to it yeah
you can imagine the first question after
he's had the injection you just say hey
Hunter Hunter just out of interest when
your dad says he knew nothing about any
of your businesses that's a lie isn't it
yeah yeah that's a lot
now where the horse yeah
Emily I don't know how no one said this
before me Hillary Clinton I want to know
what all those emails were I want to
know why I just there's so many
questions first question is how did you
get into Epstein's cell yeah oh that's a
great one yo Trace you know I would go I
would do fox because my contract
negotiations are coming up really yeah I
have enough money for you uh shut up all
right
that's just a warning
it's pretty good what is something that
you did that was really bad or forbidden
when you were younger that your parents
never figured figured out oh my God
Trace uh getting thrown in jail they no
yeah never figured it out because that
was you know was mistaked and in the old
days when you'd get pulled over you'd
get a Fix-It ticket for a life for a
tail light right you get a fix a ticket
and if you didn't have the money to fix
the taillight they would put a warrant
out for your arrest there were no
computers so the next time you got
pulled over they would take you to jail
right because that was the way it was
before computers now they can check out
they take you to jail and then you walk
in and the guy's like oh you're just
yeah you get out but you actually got
arrested and brought in jail so my
parents found out so it was a it was a
broken tail light and not the body in
the trunk that's not the body and trunk
because they never looked in the truck
exactly the smell was overpowered
still kicking back there yeah yeah piers
I was just thinking I don't think
there's anything that my parents haven't
already suffered from me that's true you
are beautiful Morgan yeah they've had to
suffer a lot I don't think there's
anything really that's left on the table
that could be worse than what they've
actually had to do where being very
careful I know you did something I did
yeah yes
[Laughter]
you can plead the fifth in this country
right right yes we don't have that in
England
Emily uh again this is probably a hard
question for you give given that you're
13. uh what is it
well I know my parents are going to
watch this so I'm sorry it's actually
not even that bad but I used to get in
trouble a lot in high school and at one
point I didn't want the dean to keep
calling my parents so I went on our
house phone machine and I blocked the
number so they never heard the
voicemails and I actually never told
them that and yeah sorry guys
but isn't that smart that's very smart
that was smart I I just I thought of
this just now that uh for one of my
dad's birthdays one of his co-workers
gave him a Playboy and it was the only
pornography in in our house and I found
out where it was hidden and I was I
don't know how old I was yeah 40.
but I uh I would um I would it was in
the laundry closet outside my bedroom
and I would go and just look at it but I
was before that age when you knew what
you were supposed to do with it
yes
it's still a mystery
ah this is a real upbeat question you
skipped me that was so sweet oh my God
I'm sorry oh I shouldn't have said
anything
come on
honey turn the television off so the
kids can't see this okay I have children
yeah
that's the secret no
where did you keep them
no no no
I I had a boy in my room oh
how old were you at least it was a boy
yeah
not that there's anything wrong with it
no I was 17. wow through the window
daughter no no no
through the window through the window
because I lived on the ground floor wow
and my dad actually knocked on the door
and I stuck a chair under the door
handle and said I'm going to sleep Daddy
and it was a it's I kind of lives in my
nightmares and my dreams
wow wow I'm aroused
am I I don't know what I'm saying
speaking of was a Portland cyclist rude
for crashing into a guy who was nude hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else